hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
I'm so excited because today in front of
me I have two of the new Nintendo
labelled kits a huge thank you to
Nintendo for sponsoring this video and
supply me with these kits because the
date that this was announced I was
freaking out with excitement it's
basically taking your switch and turning
it into a completely different thing
like this a robot for instance then
attend us which is sold separately but
right now these are the two kits that
are outs this is the Nintendo lab a
variety kit and this is the Nintendo lab
a robot kit so I think since the robot
seems to be a little bit more advanced
I'm gonna start out and learn the basics
first and we're gonna unbox B variety
kits are you guys excited because I'm
extremely excited you can make play and
discover so we've got various toy
concretions that you can make there's
the toy con piano to lick on RC car
there's actually two RC cars if you have
an extra set of joy' con controllers you
and a friend in battle against each
other
toy con motorbikes oi con house tillich
on fishing rod so enough talking let's
let's open the first thing we have here
is the software inside of here mixed up
we've got a bag of parts that we will
need to assemble all of our little toy
con creations I think this might be just
a part of the packaging I don't think
you build with this who's to say that
you can't use this to build something I
would say save it cuz later down the
line you guys are gonna get crazy and
wild and I know you're gonna be taking
every piece of cardboard that you get
from anything and making insane crazy
creations so I look forward to seeing
some of the great things do you guys
make let's take out our cardboard so
this is awesome because all of these
have really cool printed things on them
so each one of these different colors
will correspond to each toy con kit that
you're going to be making I'm saving
this box because I've a feeling that
I'll be able to turn this box into
something it may be a future robot so
here's some of the accessory parts and
what's great is a lot of these things or
things that you could potentially have
at your house already so if there is
something that you need to replace you
can easily find a rubber band or a piece
of string foam stickers
these are little reflective stickers so
it's really cool about these reflective
stickers is in the bright joy Conn
controller there is an IR motion camera
so with these reflected stickers and the
IR that is what makes all of the magic
happen I think I'm gonna start with RC
cars because I think that's gonna be the
easiest one because there's only one
sheet of cardboard I'm already so into
this I haven't even started doing
anything yet this is you can actually
zoom in to your creations you can go all
the way around it so if you're confused
as to how something is put together
there's no confusion because you can
zoom in to see exactly where things are
placed so here are the things that we
can make here on the menu screen I love
that it gives you an estimation of how
much time it's gonna take to make things
so the RC car ten minutes
it looks like the piano is the most
difficult it takes 158 to 210 minutes ok
let's start with RC card and
[Music]
that's so cool just gave me a really
quick flapper of everything that we're
gonna be doing two steps to complete
take up these two putts so this one's
flashing and it's cool because it gives
you this tutorial so there's a foreword
in the back button I keep wanting to
press down and click but you actually
just hold so that fast forwards to the
next piece of the directions that's all
we need for the RC car wait I did it
that's it oh look here it is I mean look
how cute this is it's a little cardboard
antenna like it's a little tiny hat for
your switch so we've got this first
portion done now it's time to insert the
joi con controller so I hear you just
aligned at the plus and the minus and
slide it right in like so it just got so
much cooler look at this Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
and off we go I just pushed a button and
I wasn't even ready expecting this to
happen this is crazy I'm gonna start
getting into spy stuff oh yeah
my spying is gonna go very well you're
never gonna be able to hear me there's
two different modes right here so when
you click on the screen looks like a
heat map but it's actually a depth map
it's red that means you're closer and
what's cool using the distance you can
use the auto drive feature and you can
lead it with your hand just like so as
an added bonus you can personalize any
of the creations that you make so I've
got some arts and crafts supplies here
so let's decorate our little toy con RC
car
[Music]
now that I have everything all set up
I'm gonna take this off to the table and
onto the floor so I have plenty of room
to play this is so awesome like the fact
that I'm controlling this from my
Nintendo switch using the vibration in
these droidcon controllers is just
beyond anything that I can even
comprehend right now there's also a
two-player versus mode you ring this
little bell and then if we had our
second toy con RC car and it ran into
each other the explosion but if we were
playing for real
that definitely would not have happened
to my car
next up is the toy con piano I've soaked
that I had so much fun building the RC
car this one is gonna be a little bit
more complex but I am ready for the
challenge so you can use the on screen
touch controls to fast-forward but you
could also use one of the joi cons if
that's easier for you holding a button
goes forwards and the Y button goes
backwards remove three parts from XI a
and B
[Music]
our toy car piano is complete and now
for the last final touches we put our
Nintendo switch right here into the
front and the joy pod into the back I am
a musical genius
[Applause]
this is so shocking because we started
off with a flat piece of cardboard and
now I'm playing the piano with a
Nintendo switch inserted into the front
of this that's not even the best part
because we've got these little knobs
here so each night was inserted here
into the top and as you can see this
reflective tape is basically a code to
tell them to switch what sounds to play
number one the whole screen just switch
to cats if you shake the piano slightly
at this little button you can press down
it'll also give it another effect if you
want to play a song you can press this
little play button right here number two
it's a choir are you ready for number
three I'm not sure if you are
it's insane because there are so many
possibilities with this you can even go
as far as getting rhythm cards so you
can punch out little pieces into the
cardboard and insert it here so it's
kind of like those old-school pianos if
you guys have ever seen this there's
like a little school it kind of scrolls
and automatically plays so essentially
it's along those same lines but
different and way cooler
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so now I'm going to show you guys the
inside of this thing and I know I
mentioned the reflective tape but this
is how it actually works so here is the
controller that has the IR camera built
into it now let's open this up the first
thing you'll see is when I press the
keys you hear the sound you guys will
also notice that there's a reflective
tape on each one of these keys so the
infrared sensor senses and reflects off
of the tape and that's how the sound is
created and that same thing happens
whenever you put in the different jobs
the infrared reflects off of those
reflective tapes and it tells your
switch to change the sound so this last
knob it's a circle knob and this is
called the special knob so when you
insert this basically that activates
this joy con and it puts it into sort of
like a vibration mode or an acoustic
mode so each button corresponds with a
different vibration frequency that's not
sound coming from the antenna switch
that is coming from this joy con
controller vibrating and the box is
amplifying that well as much as I've
enjoyed racing cars and playing piano my
entire goal and dream in life other than
going to space is to be a robot
and it's robot time so to make the robot
move you basically just lift your feet
and walk in place so here I am tilting
my head to give them directions and
punching buildings to destroy and if you
want to go to first-person mode just
like magic here we are inside of our
robot
hopping on the first-person mode and now
it's time to fly Wow I think I have my
Halloween costume for this year so when
you bend your legs and you crouch down
you enter tank mode
stand back up raise your arms and you're
flying destroy everything
this is definitely one of the more
complex bills this one takes around five
hours and there is so much going on
inside of this backpack but you guys
can't even see right now so when I move
my arms back and forth and my legs up
and down you can see the reflective tape
and the IR camera is picking that up so
that's how the movement is actually
happening on screen so inside of the toy
con hanger using these knobs you can
change and customize the look of your
robot also what is really fun is if you
have two of these sets using one switch
console you'll be able to battle your
robot friend thank you guys for watching
I hope you guys enjoyed this video I had
so much fun making these things but
there is still more to make play and
discover in this variety kit so with
that I will see you guys in my next
video bye I'm the robot
[Music]